les musiques du monde pour accompagner
sa concentration autour des quatre
éléments
depuis deux semaines dédiées matar
constituent les parties manquantes de
cette mystérieuse statut ils sont
arrivés un peu denses et à la à
l'atelier donc on a vraiment un état
sanitaire qui est vraiment très dégradée
avec des parties manquantes sur les
genoux les jambes les têtes sur la
partie haute
le sculpteur a tout de suite été surpris
par la qualité de l'oeuvre des détails
soignés et un style propre 18e qui n'est
pas sans rappeler les sculptures du
château de versailles
cette torsion qui tourne c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
magnifique sculpture son nom rêve tout
aussi inconnu que celui de son auteur
elles représentent les quatre éléments
l'eau la terre le feu et l'air
ce sont les deux personnages qui ont les
ailes ceux du bas n'ont pas d'elle est
donc là au moins il tend le bras en
l'air de façon à atteindre ont l'air
pour redonner la beauté de ces
détails-là la statue dédiée matar
commence par créer une forme en terre
pour ensuite faire un moulage en plâtre
une fois ce moulage parfait il sera
copié en pierre est posée sur la statue
tout ça ça n'existait pas on essaye
d'intégrer vraiment notre travail ou
patrimoine passé sans essayer de
d'inventer des choses on essaye vraiment
de respecter au maximum la sculpture
une fois terminée cette statue des
quatre éléments se retrouvera ici son
socle est déjà prêt à l'accueillir une
touche finale à la réhabilitation du
parc du château
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir une
oeuvre comme celle là dans le parc du
château
puisque ça ne fait que compléter
l'ensemble de ce que nous avons voulu
faire depuis de nombreuses années
château et statues se feront face de
vieux amis qui retrouveront chacun leur
tour les traits de leur jeunesse